how is
everything in dj head world been man i
think honestly it's been a blessing
i've i've had a chance to you know
what's crazy it's
in the this is and this is i don't think
i've ever said this before
publicly either but i remember thinking
one time during the pandemic when we was
doing our show right and this is like
right when george floyd happened yeah
and the whole [ __ ]
and so and i remember having a selfish
moment because i was thinking like damn
i remember getting one in the game me
and you would always talk about it in
the studio like
and the reason we wanted to get into
radio is to do dope interviews create
dope content
yeah create dope hip-hop moments right
whatever and
i remember the fun part of it so i
remember coming up here and this is when
mustard cracked off 2012 to 2014.
it was just la was the sound and woo
right and that was the reason why i
wanted to do it and i get
and then and the selfishness in me he
was like damn but i get race riots
police brutality
donald trump oh yeah that was like how
are you gonna lie man being on the air
during that time
the pandemic zoom was very rough the
pandemic coven 19.
we're trying to do like an actual show
over zoom about
all this wild-ass [ __ ] like la's on fire
bro and it's like i mean riots across
the country
no i'm sorry across the world right yeah
the way we had to do the show was
probably my least
favorite part of my radio career not
that we had to talk about that stuff but
just the fact that we had to do it from
our house and try to make it sound is
like
it was that [ __ ] sucked and so i
remember thinking to myself like damn
how'd i get dealt this hand as
i wanted to be in other in other you
know like
having fun and [ __ ] but then i started
thinking about it oh it's not about me
and so once i understood it's not about
me everything since then has been a
blessing like i look at
my life now is a complete blessing
everything that i'm doing